को नमस्कार आप सभी का स्वागत है जर्मन
सीखिए हिंदी में कि नेक्स्ट एपिसोड हुई आज
हम सीखने वाले हैं डेकोरेशन या बेनिफिट
किसी भी भाषा में अगर आपको बातचीत शुरू
करनी है तो सबसे इंपोर्टेंट चीज होती है
प्रश्न यह सवाल तुम कहां से आए तुम क्या
करने वाले हो तुम्हारा नाम क्या है इन सब
सवालों से ही आप बातचीत शुरु करते हो तो
यह सवाल होते हैं उनके दो टाइप सकें एक यस
नहीं क्वेश्चन यानी ऐसे सवाल जिम का आंसर
और हां या ना में दे सकते हो तुम क्रिकेट
खेलते हो ना तुम्हारा नाम किधर है ना यह
उनके एग्जांपल से
कि अब दूसरे सवाल है जिनमें आप अ एक्चुली
इन्फॉर्मेशन ले रहे हो तुम क्या करते हो
तुम कहां से आए हैं तुम क्रिकेट क्यों
खेलते हो इन क्वेश्चंस को इंग्लिश में डे
क्वेश्चंस बोलते हैं यह जर्मन में वे फागण
बोलते हैं क्योंकि मोस्ट ऑफ यह सवाल जो है
वह डब्ल्यू एक्स रोते व्हाट वन इन इंग्लिश
ओके तो चलो हम्म शुरू करते हैं जज
क्वेश्चंस ठीक है
अब तो हिंदी में आप कैसे पूछते हो भाई हां
तुम क्या खेलते हो तुम क्या खेलते हो और
उसका आंसर क्या देते हो तुम मैं क्रिकेट
खेलता हूं इंग्लिश में आप यह कैसे पूछोगे
व्हाट डू यू प्ले वांट यू प्ले आप आंसर
दोगे आई प्ले करेक्ट करेक्ट है पड़ी डो
कहां चला गया
इस सवाल में तो चार शिद्दत है व्हाट डू यू
प्ले अनशन में तो आया आई प्ले क्रिकेट
दुकान चला गया हिंदी में देखो तुम क्या
खेलते हो मैं क्रिकेट खेलता हूं चार शब्द
तो यह जो दूर है वह अंग्रेजी की लिमिटेशंस
अंग्रेजी भी पूछ सकता था व्हाट प्लेस यू
व्हाट प्लेस यू पर अंग्रेजों ने नहीं पूछा
यह अंग्रेजी कैलीबरेशन यह लिमिटेशंस जर्मन
में नहीं है जर्मन में उड़ डायरेक्ट वैसे
ही पूछ सकते हो वक्त पीछे दो सिंपल पहली
पोजीशन पर क्या मतलब वह ब्लॉट दूसरी मुझे
डायरेक्ट वर्ड की जरूरत ही नहीं प्लीज और
मींस क्यों हुआ क्योंकि दूर है
मैं वाट्सप इंप्रूव तुम क्या खेलते हो
सिंपल पहली पोजीशन अधूरी प्रदूषण व तीसरी
पोजिशन नऊ वास स्प्रेड दूर तुम क्या खेलते
हो वास तेज धूप तुम क्या पीली हो
ए क्लियर है सबको अभी मैं आपको एक और चीज
बताता हूं जिससे आप का काम और आसान हो जाए
तो जनरल यह क्वेश्चंस फॉर सिचुएशन में
पूछते हैं तो कैसे होगा कि जब आप किसी को
पूछ रहा है वह क्वेश्चन अगर आप फैमिली पूछ
रहे हो तो उसको भी अच्छा लगेगा कि आप उसको
आंसर दे रहे हो और आपके लिए अच्छा कि अगर
आपको याद हो गया दूर कर फॉर्मल रूप क्या
है कैपिटल जी और वह चलता कैसे हैं वीरों
की तरह मतलब इंफिनिटिव फॉर्म्स में रहता
है तो दो के लिए आपको स्पिल्स करना पड़ा
पर जी के लिए उत्पीड़न तो वह स्पीड दूर
तुम क्या कहते हो वाष्पीकरण जी आप क्या
खेलते हो
कि मात्र * तू क्या पीता है वास्तु
रिंगटोन सीईए आप कहते हो व्हाट्सएप वृद्धि
आप क्या खाते हो
मैं अपने लिए भी अच्छा कि हमको चलाना नहीं
पड़ा व को सामने वाले को भी अच्छा लगता है
सामने वाला भी खुश कि मैं उसको आदर्श हमने
बुलाया तो जब को कंसेप्ट ईयर है पहले
पोजीशन पर प्ले लिस्ट ए क्वेश्चन दूसरी
पोजीशन पर तीसरी पोजीशन पर नाव और फिर बाद
में जो भी आपका कुछ अगर एक्स्ट्रा हो तो
अगर यह क्लियर है तो बाकी एकदम सिंपल है
अब हमको बाकि सारे दिल्ली स्टेट क्वेश्चन
सीखने बोर्ड जो है उनकी तो एक तो हमको पता
है वह इस मतलब व्हाट नेक्स्ट इंपॉर्टेंट
इस वह कहां व ओके और उसके इन दो वेरियंट्स
होते हैं कहां से वह और फ्रॉम व या फिर
कहां को वहीं पूरे लुक नेक्स्ट वरुम क्यों
मैं क्यों या फिर वी मतलब कैसे
हेलो हाउ ओके नेक्स्ट है 151 मतलब पिकअप
वैन फिर है वह रॉ मतलब कॉम खूब सिर्फ करने
में एक बार रिवाइज करता हूं इस वर्ष सिर्फ
इंग्लिश सकता हूं
कि वह मतलब व उसके दो वेरियंट्स है वह ऐड
मतलब फ्रॉम व है वहीं मतलब टू व वारों
मतलब y51 वी मतलब हाउ और व मतलब को वास
मतलब वह तो हमको पता है तो जरूर उसे देखते
हैं क्रिकेट खेलने ओके तो क्या होगा वह
उपलब्धि फिर से समझ लो पहले फिर और दूसरी
पहले दूसरी व तीसरी पोजीशन करना और फिर सब
कुछ तुम्हारा वंशवृद्धि क्रिकेट
ऐसा क्यों करते हो गई क्रिकेट वाराणसी अप
कि कैसे खेलते हो क्रिकेट वीएनसी क्रिकेट
फोन कहां खेलते हुए क्रिकेट बोस की रणजी
क्रिकेट सिंपल एसिड क्वेश्चन बदल रहा है
बाकी कुछ नहीं चलो 301 खा लिया जाए क्यों
खाते हो कि वालों ने संधि पिज्जा कब खाते
होंगे इस वंश वीएस आस
फोन कहां खाते होगी क्या वह संजीत आप किसी
भी चीज का जैसे-जैसे आपकी आदत हो जाएगी
आपको आसान हो जाएगा क्योंकि तेल ऊपर सी
वरुण टिंकल जिप्सी कैसे खाते हो पिज्जा
20mg पिज़्ज़ा और लास्ट में कौन हो तुम तू
कौन है अगर विदाउट स्पेस पूछना है तू कौन
है व ट्विस्ट धूप क्योंकि 2 मिनट वेयर
रिड्यूस्ड ड्यू और अगर खोजना है आदर से आप
कौन है वह अर्जेंट जी
कि यह Vivo बेसिक फॉरवर्ड एकदम सिंपल है
अगर आपको पूछना है कहां खेलते हो क्रिकेट
कि वह पहले क्वेश्चन तिलक जी क्रिकेट एकदम
सिंपल सकती है सबको एकदम अब और थोड़ी सी
आगे इंट्रस्टिंग बात बताता हूं थोड़ा सा
एडवांस लेवल है पर मुझे लगता है कि हमने
आपको सीखना चाहिए तो छोटी सी बात है जब
इंग्लिश में बोलते हो बीच वॉच वीडियो है
बीच व्हाट डू यू है या फिर हाउ मेनी का
कर्ज भी है
है तो ऐसे थोड़ी देर क्योंकि वह वृक्ष तो
आ गया फिर सेकंड पोजिशन पर तो डू आना
चाहिए नहीं रहे क्योंकि पिच मौजूद एक ही
पोजीशन है या फिर हाउ मेनी कार एक ही
पोजीशन है हिंदी में भी सेम यह कितनी
गाड़ियां है तुम्हारे पास कितनी गाड़ियां
एक साथ बोलते हो तो यह फिर कौन-कौन सी
घड़ी है तुम्हारे पास अक्ल कौन सी घड़ी एक
तुम एक साथ ही ले रहे कंसेप्ट ईयर सब को
फिर से इंग्लिश से बताता हूं आप ऐसे नहीं
पूछते हाउ कार्डियो है वह मैंने या फिर
हाउ टू हाउ टू यू हैव मेनका नहीं करके
क्यों क्योंकि हाउ मेनी कार यह एक पोजीशन
है कल जब यह सब को
इस बीच वह एक पोजीशन है
थे सेकंड में जिक्र भी आ रहा है दूध पर वह
नंबर नहीं पकड़ो एक पोजीशन तीन वर्ड की हो
सकती है
कि आयोग सबको कंसेप्ट क्लियर अगर आपको यह
कंसेप्ट इंग्लिश में क्लियर है तो जर्मन
में भी सेम है
कि जर्मन में विच को बोलते हैं वे चक्र
उसका भी वैष्णव वैष्णव इंचेस होता है वह
जब हम कैसे सीखेंगे तब सीखेंगे अभी के लिए
व्हेन शे आईएस गुड इनफ
है तो विच टू यू है अब वैश्य व एक पोजीशन
ही अपन जी वैष्णव व हवन जी हाउ मेनी
कार्ड्स आर यू हैव हाउ वी मेक मतलब फील
कार सिरसा टो वीप फील डॉक्टोर्स बंधी
कंडक्टर सबको फील मुकेश एक ही पोजीशन है
हुआ था आई डोंट सबको कंसेप्ट समझ में आए
हैं तक हम रिवाइज करते हैं सब कुछ सबसे
पहले हम ने क्या बोला कि वापिस तू हमको
इंग्लिश कि जैसे डू की जरूरत ही नहीं है
व्हाट प्रयोग लेकिन जरूरत ही नहीं व्हाट
प्लेस यू वाच्ड पीस दूं फिर हमने बोला है
कि वह इसका थोड़ा सा हम कर लेते हैं आप
पूछते हैं वर्ष क्लेंसी उसके बाद हमने
सारे टैबलेट एक क्वेश्चन देखिए वह व्वी यह
सारे डे क्वेश्चन हमने और Airtel हमने
बोला रूल हम ने क्या बोला पहली पोजीशन पर
डब्लू इस क्वेश्चन का वर्ड सेकेंड पोजीशन
पर व तीसरी पोजीशन पर नाव और बाद में जो
भी आपका हो और दो एक्सेप्शनल छोटी सी देखी
कि बाहर
कि वेश्याओं और हां बंधी और बीपी लव
स्टोरीस हवन जी दोनों में व्यक्तियों व और
बीपीएल मुकेश एक ही पोजीशन है तो रूम अभी
भी फॉलो हो रहा है आई हो सबको यह दिल्ली
स्टेट क्वेश्चन का कंसेप्ट समझ में आया
होगा next एपिसोड में हम देखेंगे इस नए
क्वेश्चंस और रिक्वेस्ट
झालावार